[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Marc fenau bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire en étant
ensemble pendant un peu plus de 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour
on va évidemment parler du modèle
agricole de futurs notre modèle agricole
Marc phénom mais d'abord un mot de la
grippe aviaire puisque des annonces de
cadre gris pavières ces dernières heures
dans le Gard dans l'Aude combien y
a-t-il de cas à l'heure actuelle sur le
territoire une cinquantaine de cas
depuis le début de l'été avec un
phénomène particulier c'est que
d'habitude la grippe aviaire elle vient
avec les migrations d'oiseaux
automnales or la grippe aviaire est
restée sur le sol français dans la faune
sauvage comme on dit et donc elle
réapparaît un peu plus tôt et elle
réparait assez fortement on a déjà élevé
le niveau de risque de faible à modérer
on est en train de regarder si il va
falloir prendre des mesures
complémentaires
pour essayer de protéger le maximum
d'élevage dans une période qui est comme
vous le savez on a beaucoup pas
accompagné la filière jurez salué les
efforts de la filière l'État a mis un
milliard 100 millions d'euros pour
accompagner les pertes et aussi pour
faire évoluer ce qu'on appelle la
densification pour faire en sorte que
les élevages soient mieux protégés et
puis deux on a un sujet particulier à
l'ouest puisque c'était la zone où se
concentrer à ce qu'on appelle les
accouvoirs les zones où on produit les
jeunes canetons en particulier qui vont
après dans d'autres élevages et donc on
a besoin de protéger absolument parce
qu'il y a de la ressources génétique il
y a de la qualité de produits à venir et
donc on a besoin de travailler donc on
va regarder là dans les heures et les
jours qui viennent s'il y a de nécessité
ou non d'élever le niveau de risque
qu'on est dans un niveau de risque qui
est très important on l'avait déjà fait
il y a un certain nombre de pays qui il
y a un certain nombre de pays qui l'ont
déjà fait d'ailleurs donc on va regarder
qu'est-ce qui vous ferait prendre cette
décision c'est la dynamique au mauvais
sens du terme de de
cette de cette épidémie c'est-à-dire le
nombre d'élevage concernés et la
répartition géographique souvent sur les
zones de migration d'abord est-ce que
justement sur ces zones de migration il
faut prendre des mesures de notamment
les mesures comprend généralement c'est
des mesures qui visent à confiner
ça fait partie de la panoplie des
mesures mais vous permettrez qu'on en
discute avec les représentants
professionnels parce que c'est des
mesures qui sont compliquées à prendre
des mesures qui sont difficiles pour les
éleveurs et donc il faut aussi qu'on
travaille avec eux pour voir comment on
ajuste au mieux ces difficultés là il y
a de nouveaux abattages qui sont prévus
bah c'est la règle quand un élevage et
quand un élevage est contaminé il y a
des abattages il y a des zones de
d'exclusion on fait du vide sanitaire
donc le protocole est assez connu par
ailleurs on travaille pour ajuster
depuis quelques mois parce que c'est une
demande qui n'était pas illégitime il
faut les payer par la science regardez
les élevages qui sont en plein air
regardez ceux qui qui sont des labels de
plein air regardez ce qu'on peut faire
pour ajuster les choses et puis les
espoirs qu'on nourrit autour de la mise
en place d'un vaccin puisqu'on avait
obtenu Julien denormandie et moi dans sa
suite mais c'est Julien de Normandie qui
avait beaucoup travaillé pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse obtenir une
expérimentation vaccinale qui est en
cours et dont on aura des résultats dans
l'hiver non non
vous savez que sur les vaccins il faut
toujours avoir un peu de recul en animal
comme en humain et donc on a besoin
d'avoir un peu de recul vous avez vu
qu'il y a la nouveauté le fait que la
grippe aviaire était restée sur le sol
français finalement tout l'année il y a
plus de saisonnalité est-ce que est-ce
qu'on sait pourquoi non on est en train
d'y travailler avec le nom de ces avec
les spécialistes de la question les
ornitos aussi on ne sait pas bien
pourquoi il faut reconnaître parfois
quand on ne sait pas et que la science
ne peut pas éclairer on est en train d'y
travailler pour regarder pourquoi en
faune sauvage est resté cette année vous
avez des infos sur l'état de la faune
sauvage justement parce que c'est la
satellite elle ne dessine pas que les
Élevages
non gouvernementale de protection de
l'environnement notamment avec la LPO je
pourrais essayer de déterminer alors on
a eu des cas dans certains c'est plutôt
circonscrit mais parfois il y a des
éléments difficiles en faut sauvage
parce que c'est par nature des tous les
animaux ne sont pas recensés il y a ceux
d'abord qui sont porteurs et qui qui
t'ont peu malade parce qu'ils sont moins
sensibles vous avez les espèces qui sont
pas particulièrement on a eu du cormoran
enfin on a un certain
voilà on a vu ça en Bretagne en
particulier plutôt de cette région là on
le voit physiquement et donc le risque
aussi c'est alors ça on peut pas y faire
malheureusement grand chose on l'a vu
aussi au Canada on l'a vu au nord de
l'Europe des populations de faune
sauvages qui sont assez en risque est-ce
que le risque à l'arrivée c'est qu'on
soit on finisse par avoir un élevage à
vierge qui ne puisse plus avoir de
l'élevage en extérieur mais c'est pour
ça qu'on essaye de travailler c'est
c'est un des risques mais la vaccination
peut être un élément puis il faut qu'on
dose notre réponse aussi à ce que nous
dit la science au fur et à mesure on a
des connaissances plus nombreuses sur
cette sur cette épidémie de grippe
aviaire et donc c'est ça qu'on essaie de
regarder de Loris ça peut être celui-là
et donc c'est ce sur ce sur quoi il faut
qu'on travaille un dernier mot puisqu'on
approche de Noël est-ce que la filière
foie gras française est en danger
aujourd'hui alors elle a été en danger
elle reste en grande fragilité parce que
tous les élevages n'ont pas pu avoir les
animaux dont ils avaient besoin pour
produire du foie gras simplement je
voudrais saluer d'abord la capacité de
résilience de cette filière qui qui
permettra d'avoir du foie gras pour les
fêtes de fin d'année mais évidemment
c'est un équilibre fragile ce qu'il va y
avoir une baisse de production et donc
on aura des éléments on aura deux quoi à
voir et fournir en foie gras évidemment
en moins grande quantité que les années
précédentes pour des questions de
recherche mais ça ça a été vu avec la
filière il le savent pas forcément
légère mais pas forcément très
significatif et des aides prévues pour
cette ont été faites à la fois pour
couvrir les pertes liées à
l'enfermement ou à la destruction de
parfois de d'élevage entier pour des
raisons sanitaires et puis par ailleurs
pour accompagner la filière
sur la question des bassines puisqu'il y
a 10 jours avait lieu une manifestation
interdite d'opposants au bassines à
Sainte Soline dans les Deux-Sèvres parmi
les manifestants il y avait des députés
dont Sandrine Rousseau et 36 députés de
la majorité à l'Assemblée dont des modem
ont écrit à la présidente et El brune
Pivet pour demander des sanctions contre
les députés présents dans ces
manifestations interdites disant avoir
été choqué par leur présence et que ce
type de comportement abîme l'image de
l'Assemblée c'est ce qui a écrit dans
leur lettre est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça alors moi il
m'appartient pas j'étais aux Relations
avec le Parlement d'interférer dans les
décisions disciplinaires de l'Assemblée
deuxième élément je pense que c'est pas
permettrait de dire je pense que c'est
pas la seule voie on peut aussi essayer
de faire entendre raison aux uns aux
autres quand vous êtes parlementaires
vous votez la loi
et donc vous entendez que la loi soit
respectée donc quand vous êtes
parlementaire et vous allez sur le site
d'une manifestation qui est interdite et
deuxièmement sur un projet qui lui a
respecté l'ensemble des critères de la
loi qui a purgé tous les recours qui
étaient possibles et qui par ailleurs en
reparlera peut-être à plein de vertus je
trouve qu'on fait des fois à son député
parce que sur d'autres sujets sur
lesquels c'est même député pourrait
trouver que la loi est bien qu'est-ce
qu'on fera le jour ou d'autres personnes
viendront sur telle ou tel endroit pour
dire moi je ne respecte pas la loi donc
la loi elle est pas de vitesse donc j'en
appelle un peu à la raison de chacun la
loi en démocratie si on commence à se
mettre dans le
la philosophie de ne pas respecter la
loi et d'inciter à ne pas respecter la
loi dans une manifestation dont on
savait qu'elle pouvait produire des
risques violents au fond vous accréditer
malgré vous parfois d'ailleurs vous
accrédité parfois les phénomènes
violents je répète parfois malgré vous
et deux en démocratie le principe de
base c'est de respecter la loi sinon
c'est la loi du plus fort qui va
s'imposer est-ce que le chantier a
repris sur place il est en cours j'ai
pas des éléments récents mais le
chantier va reprendre il a repris
au citron
aux demandes des manifestants qui
demandent à mon compte
vous savez comme enfin vous savez comme
moi que les chantiers reprennent au gré
parfois de d'événements qui n'ont pas de
lien avec des manifestations mais la
volonté c'est que le chantier reprenne
c'est bien pour ça d'ailleurs que nous
avons fait en sorte que il y a pas eu de
dégradation majeure sur le site parce
qu'il faut que ce chantier reprenne
pourquoi parce que ce projet il a été
validé il a été y compris validé par des
associations de protection de
l'environnement et donc il faut que se
sentait sinon là aussi on donnerait
raison au casseurs on donnerait raison à
ceux qui comme seul moyen d'action une
fois qu'ils ont purgé les moyens légaux
utilisent des moyens illégaux c'est un
peu pas marcher comme ça en démocratie
excusez-moi mais dans un passé récent on
a eu l'exemple de l'aéroport
Notre-Dame-des-Landes où tous les tous
les recours juridiques avaient été
purgés il y a eu un référendum local etc
le projet était validé il devait se
faire il s'est jamais fait donc je ne
sais plus si tous les recours peut
juridiques avaient été purgé mais en
tout état de cause mais là reconnaissons
pour avoir suivi à l'époque j'étais
décision de groupe du groupe modem à
l'Assemblée nationale que nous avions un
abcès de fixation et un point de
fixation avec des phénomènes de violence
qui était très prégnants et deux une
difficulté ce qu'on peut avoir le même
type de
ce qu'on a fait en sorte c'est ça ce
qu'on a fait en sorte d'éviter il y a
une dizaine de jours pour éviter qu'il y
a des points de fixation et que des gens
viennent s'installer sur des territoires
pour empêcher que des projets puissent
être à vrai dire sur
Notre-Dame-des-Landes juste pour dire un
mot un projet qui a 30 ans de recul
parce que c'est presque 30 ans il faut
se poser la question quand même de
pourquoi il a mis 30 ans avec autant
d'atternements parce que pour avoir été
le local je reste élu local quand un
projet met 30 ans à sortir de terre
c'est qu'il y a peut-être des questions
à se poser et les bassines sont vraiment
indispensables l'agriculture française
on a besoin aujourd'hui dans le contexte
qui est le nôtre
je suis désolé de rappeler des choses
qui sont un peu des évidences s'il y a
pas d'eau il y a pas d'agriculture et
quand il y a pas d'eau pendant 4 mois il
y a pas d'agriculture et quel que soit
les cultures du maraîchage aux prairies
quel que soit les cultures il y a besoin
d'eau deuxième élément on a un rythmie
de la pluviométrie on le voit très bien
cette année on a un mois deux mois trois
mois sans aucune goutte d'eau j'ai vécu
ça dans mon propre département
j'étais l'autre jour dans la Marne au
mois de septembre si j'ai bonne mémoire
ils ont eu 300 mm d'eau donc il y a une
nécessité à stocker l'eau donc les
moyens de stocker l'eau arythmie le GIEC
c'est pas moi qui me dit le GIEC dit
même quantité d'eau qui va tomber donc
on a besoin dans les périodes où il y a
beaucoup d'eau de pouvoir la retenir
sinon elle file à l'océan pardon de
cette phrase un peu bizarre mais l'océan
n'a pas besoin d'eau de ces quantités
d'eau là quand ça va quand ça tombe
fortement en particulier quand c'est des
plus orageux ça file en moins de 8 jours
à l'océan et donc on a besoin dans ces
périodes-là de retenir cette eau pour
que dans les périodes de baseaux dans
les périodes où on a plus d'eau on
puisse la restituer pour pour
l'irrigation mais on peut cette question
là il se pose pour l'irrigation elle se
pose pour le soutien des étiages de
cours d'eau elle se pose pour
l'alimentation eau potable et à
l'inverse elle se pose pour les
incendies y compris dans l'Ouest et y
compris dans le nord de la France on a
assisté cette année ce qui est une
nouveauté à des incendies dans des
forêts qui auraient pu penser qu'un jour
on nous dirait qu'il y avait un organe
en forêt Bruxelles et donc et puis
dernier élément et l'autre pouce c'est
pour lutter aussi contre les inondations
parce que quand il y a beaucoup d'eau
donc c'est à la fois vertueux quand on
manque d'eau et vertu quand il y a trop
d'eau parce que ça permet de stocker un
peu d'eau et d'éviter qu'elle déborde
mais est-ce qu'il y a d'autres pistes
que sébastine que Sébastien
le principe de ces réserves de
substitution c'est un principe on pompe
dans la nappe en période hivernale c'est
le principe de ce projet dans le moment
avec on pompe ce qui est autorisé c'est
pas donc le bar n'est pas ouvert si vous
permettez cette expression on pompe la
quantité qui est autorisée en fonction
du niveau de la nappe dans ce territoire
en particulier ce sont des nappes qui
réagissent beaucoup à la pluviométrie
dès qu'il pleut la nappe se remplit
c'est pas le cas dans mon territoire
dans mon territoire la percolation de la
nappe jusqu'à la nappe est beaucoup plus
lente et donc là on a on a des mesures
d'une autre nature mais ici c'est dans
sous cette modalité là dans d'autres cas
c'est des réserves colinaires plus
classiques dans des troisième cas c'est
des ouvrages plus importants je pense à
l'ouvrage qui a été fait il y a 60 ans
de Serre-Ponçon qui qui s'il n'existait
pas aujourd'hui il y aurait plus
d'agriculture dans une grande partie de
la vallée du Rhône jusqu'au delta c'est
comme ça que ça se passerait donc la
multiplicité des outils et puis dire
aussi que parallèlement et c'est le
projet de Sainte-Soline en particulier
comme la plupart des projets c'est des
projets qui par ailleurs portent des
exigences pour les agriculteurs en
particulier la réduction de la
consommation d'eau dans cet état une
contrepartie parce que c'est il y a des
contreparties
elles sont sur la table elles sont
signées ça fait partie du protocole et
les opposants les plus virulents et de
mauvaise foi il y a beaucoup de gens
aussi dans ces associations qui sont de
bonne foi mais là il y en a qui sont
mauvaise foi qui disent ils vont pas les
respecter alors
corrobor ce qu'ils disent c'est à dire
que il y a aucun engagement qui tient la
loi ne tient pas les engagements ne
tiennent pas il y a des engagements qui
ont été pris
qui avait plus de 20 millions de mètres
cubes qui étaient pris sur cette dans ce
territoire pour l'agrégation on est plus
qu'à 12
et sur les 12 il y en aura plus que 6
qui seront pris en période estivale
répète on passe de 20 donc assis mais
pourquoi parce qu'il faut travailler sur
des cultures moins gourmandes dans l'eau
parce qu'on a besoin gourmande parce que
on a l'irrigation qui est plus de
précision le plan France relance il sera
poursuivi d'ailleurs dans France 2030 va
permettre d'accompagner des systèmes
d'irrigation qui permettent de que
chaque goutte d'eau soit utile si vous
permettez cette cette expression pour
finir sur cette question de l'eau est-ce
qu'il faut aussi travailler sur le
traitement des eaux usées sur la
récupération ça fait partie alors il y a
deux sujets si vous permettez parce que
c'est un sujet important et c'est
important qu'on puisse dire les choses
il y a d'abord un certain nombre de
masse d'eau qui sont peu utilisés il y a
beaucoup d'ouvrages en France
et qui peut-être pourrait être mobilisé
je pense au canots qui sont parfois très
en basés et qu'on aurait besoin de
désenvaser parce que ça ferait des
masses d'eau qui sont considère parfois
que dans certains territoires un tiers
du volume d'eau qui pourrait être stocké
dans les canaux n'est pas stockable du
fait d'un engagement qui est trop
important donc il faut qu'on travaille
sur ces masses d'eau qui existe déjà les
ouvrages existent déjà qu'on pourrait
qu'on pourrait mobiliser et puis de la
réutilisation des eaux des eaux de
station
comme on dit en France c'est 1% de l'eau
qui est réutilisée en Italie c14% en
Espagne c'est 8%
Californie c'est 80% que je sache il y a
pas de sujets sanitaire qui était posé
par cela donc on a besoin de développer
une culture qui soit une culture de la
réutilisation d'ailleurs c'est valable
pour l'agriculture c'est valable aussi
pour l'agroalimentaire juste une
précision sur la sécheresse on est on
est toujours en état de stress ou pas et
à quoi il est toujours un état
sécheresse réunirai dans les prochaines
semaines aussi on va regarder où on en
est de parce que là on rentre dans la
phase où pour les cultures puisque il y
a peu de choses qui nécessitent beaucoup
d'appel d'eau on rentre en période
automnale et hivernale la crainte c'est
et la vigilance
pour l'instant on n'est pas ce stade là
il y a beaucoup de départements qui sont
encore en vigilance avec des mesures de
restriction parfois encore faibles mais
qui existe encore parce que les nappes
se sont pas rechargés que ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'on s'attende à une année
on peut avoir une année catastrophe
l'année prochaine comme cette année
c'est pas comme ça que vous le dites
c'est pas comme ça que je vous le dire
j'essaie de pas être collapsologue
chaque mois parce que sinon ça va être
compliqué pour chacun d'entre nous en
tout cas faut être vigilant oui parce
que c'est de la recherche de la nappe de
la pluie géométrie qui va tomber dépend
l'année qui va venir on va parler des
hausses de prix Stéphane oui alors
concernant les hausses de prix Bruno Le
Maire dit qu'il n'y a pas eu de
profiteur de distribution dans
l'alimentaire ni les agriculteurs ni les
distributeurs ni l'industrie
agroalimentaire donc pris au passage de
rémunération excessive est-ce que vous
confirmez c'était notre intuition c'est
d'ailleurs le rapport il avait pu
objectiver c'est objectiver dans le
rapport d'ailleurs qui a été qui a été
produit pas par mois par des inspecteurs
qui ont fait des choses sérieusement
Sonic au cœur de l'été il y avait une
polémique de certaines enseignes qui
disait il y a des profiteurs de guerre
donc et donc ce rapport démontre
l'inverse c'est-à-dire que tout le monde
augmentation des tarifs alors c'est un
deuxième sujet qui me permettait mais
sur l'augmentation des tarifs les tarifs
les hausses qui ont été passés et
parfois on est encore un peu loin je
pense à la transformation ou la
transformation elle est à la fois la
répercussion des prises agricoles et
puis la répercussion de tous les coins
du après quand vous transforme et
l'appel d'énergie et les emballages de
nature diverses qui font des surcos et
donc là on a encore des difficultés mais
je crois de ce point de vue là les
opérateurs ils ont essayé d'être
raisonna pour une raison simple c'est
qu'en phase 2 ils ont des consommateurs
et donc il faut essayer d'être modéré
dans les choses le deuxième chose que
dit le rapport c'est que égali m'a
plutôt bien fonctionné
et qui l'a permis alors ça veut pas dire
que c'est parfait quand on dit ça quand
on dit ça plutôt bien fonctionné ça fait
aussi
mais la question n'est pas d'être
autosatisfait ça plutôt bien fonctionné
alors évidemment la crise du crayon
vient percuter parce qu'on a des hausses
d'inflation qui sont très fortes mais ça
a plutôt bien fonctionné mais c'est à
quelle conséquence juste la crise
ukrainienne sur la conséquence que quand
vous avez une inflation qui est comme ça
exponentielle évidemment la répercussion
des hausses se fait parfois à des temps
dans un pas de temps qui est trop lent
et donc une charge de trésorerie pour
les pour les producteurs qui est parfois
trop forte et puis cette année enfin
d'année là les questions des coûts
énergétiques qui montent encore et qui
pose des problèmes à d'autres types de
production je pense aux endiges je pense
aux pommes de terre enfin je pense à un
certain nombre de secteurs qu'on va
accompagner qu'on va tâcher
d'accompagner deuxième et troisième
élément notamment pour les handicapés
on est en train de caler un dispositif
qui permettra de je le pense et je le
crois je l'espère de répondre à ces
exigences là même si c'est difficile
pour tout le monde reconnaissons le
après est-ce que les opérateurs ont
toujours joué le jeu vous avez vu par
ailleurs que sur la sollicitation des
ministères de l'économie et ministère de
l'Agriculture salut elle travaille qui a
été fait avec Roland Lescure et Olivier
agrégoire on a travaillé sur ce qu'on
appelle les pénalités logistiques la
direction générale de la répression des
fraudes a constaté qu'il y avait des
opérateurs
qui visent en fait à dire que quand vous
n'êtes pas livré dans les temps alors
parfois ça mériterait d'être montré un
jour il y a pas de secret sans donner le
nom de l'ancienne parce qu'on n'est pas
là pour faire ça mais des gens qui
arrivent avec 5 minutes de retard et on
leur affiche des pénalités logistiques
vous savez les difficultés qu'il y a eu
sur le gasoil quand vous avez les
difficultés qui a trouvé des des
chauffeurs pour conduire allez appliquer
une pénalité à la première minute de
retard et donc c'est pénalité vise à
dire vous avez du retard et donc je vous
demande une réfraction sur la façon on
voit pas de réintroduire rétrocommission
qui existait dans la disposition et
c'est pour ça qu'elles ont été encadrées
c'est pour ça qu'on avait demandé un
moratoire d'ailleurs globalement pour
essayer de d'avoir des pratiques
commerciales sauf fournisseurs qui est
de mauvaise foi qui ne veut pas livrer
mais globalement les transformateurs ce
qui fournissent la grande distribution
ils essaient de le faire dans des
conditions qui sont pas faciles en ce
moment parce qu'il manque des emballages
et donc c'était une manière utiliser
d'essayer de retrouver la marge ce que
vous êtes en train de nous dire c'est
que la loi égali m'a permis de de
d'améliorer les conditions de
rémunération des producteurs des
agriculteurs eux-mêmes donc ça c'est
plutôt positif plutôt positif par contre
pour tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
opérateur intermédiaire les transports
sur une grosse pression la grande
distribution un sujet à travailler avec
eux qu'il faudra qu'on travaille avec
eux de désormais cette chaîne
supplémentaire les industries
agroalimentaires comme on dit qu'ils
doivent retrouver de la marge et c'est
un élément important
parce que c'est important est-ce
qu'au-delà des gamines il va y avoir des
mesures prises en ces temps d'inflation
pour aider les agriculteurs il y a des
mesures qui ont été prises dans le plan
de résilience Ukraine des mesures pour
prendre en charge des cotisations
sociales ici prendre en charge
l'alimentation animale tout ça c'est
presque 600 millions d'euros qui ont été
mis sur la table et puis deux ils
rentreront dans le dispositif qu'on est
en train de finaliser notamment pour les
plus petits producteurs de d'entreprises
énergo intensive pour alléger la charge
de l'énergie une partie en aide une
partie de ce que font les uns et les
autres et puis une partie évidemment
dans les prix
sur le chèque alimentaire un dernier mot
là-dessus c'était une promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron alors que l'inflation
sur les produits alimentaires grimpent
évidemment est-ce qu'il va avoir le jour
alors on a plusieurs phases dans cette
affaire-là logique alimentaire c'est une
la première ministre le président de la
République ont toujours dit que c'était
un horizon sur lequel il fallait essayer
d'aller au-delà des sujets budgétaires
qui peuvent évidemment être prennent on
a lancé hier avec Jean-Christophe combe
un premier dispositif d'aide alimentaire
de 60 millions d'euros qui viendra
s'adresser en particulier aux
associations qui œuvrent dans le soutien
alimentaire aux banques alimentaires
dont il faut saluer le travail deuxième
élément sur chaque alimentaire la
difficulté dans laquelle on est c'est
d'essayer de trouver un outil ou un
dispositif unique qui essaie de répondre
à trop d'équations et à trop d'inconnus
parce que on veut en faire quoi de ce
chèque alimentaire pour moi du chèque
alimentaire se produit de la convention
citoyenne ça montre que quand même il y
a des choses qui ont été contrairement à
ceux qui parfois disent rien n'a été
produit par la Convention citoyenne on
pourrait penser au zéro
artificialisation net même si c'est un
autre débat tout ça c'est le résultat de
ça la convention citoyenne elle disait
il faut qu'on puisse se permettre au
plus démunis d'AC une alimentation de
qualité et diverses c'est ça l'objectif
et donc alimentation de qualité il y a
des tas de débats qui sont sur quel type
de produit est-ce que c'est les produits
transformés ou est-ce que c'est les
produits frais quel mode de distribution
est-ce que c'est la grande distribution
ou est-ce que c'est les circuits plus
directs est-ce que ça passe par les
banques alimentaires première étape les
moyens qu'on met en œuvre je crois que
ça a été plutôt salué par les
entreprises par les associations de
d'aide alimentaire première étape c'est
celle-là et on est en train de
retravailler avec Jean-Christophe on
pourra avoir un dispositif il faut qu'on
essaie de faire le plus clair possible
le plus simple possible mais il fera pas
tout il va pas répondre à la fois au
sujet de décarbonation au sujet de
filière au sujet de revenus des
agriculteurs et au sujet
on travaille de travailler sur un
dispositif pour regarder de quel horizon
faut qu'on regarde dans les dans les
mois qui viennent il faut qu'on essaie
de stabiliser des choses dans un cadre
budgétaire aussi qui est contraint il y
a une première mesure alimentaire qui a
été prise à l'automne vous en souvenez
au mois de septembre 100 euros par foyer
depuis des mini plus 50 euros par enfant
c'est une forme de réponse alimentaire
donc mais on a besoin d'un dispositif
qui soit mieux cal aujourd'hui
ciblage à tout point de vue quel quel
type de quelle population quel type de
produit et quels objectifs sur un tout
autre sujet peut-être un mot sur le
l'état de la forêt en France ça fait
partie de force pour toi après les
grands incendies de l'été où est-ce
qu'on en est comment rebois ce pays
selon quelle politique alors état de la
forêt c'est paradoxalement on sait
d'ailleurs bercer depuis des dizaines
d'années sur l'idée que la forêt
progressée en surface c'est vrai
factuellement la forêt progression
surface sauf que sa fonction de stockage
carbone diminue presque la moitié moins
de stockage carbone c'est du 10 ou 15
dernières années vous avez des essences
qui sont particulièrement menacés et
puis même pas seulement les résineux il
y a un certain nombre de feuillus des
châtaigniers qui ne supportent pas les
épisodes de stress hydrique qui sont
trop importants donc on a un sujet forêt
française en train de changer oui la
forêt française est en train de changer
malgré elle si je peux dire et donc on a
besoin de d'abord un on a besoin de
détailler encore d'un point de vue de
recherche on est en train d'accompagner
avec ma collègue de la recherche un
certain nombre de dispositifs et on aura
sans doute des annonces dans les
semaines qui viennent descriptif de
recherche puissant avec l'INRA et avec
d'autres pour faire en sorte qu'on voit
les essences qu'il faut pas se tromper
parce que une fois qu'on s'est trompé on
part pour 80 années ou plus donc c'est
le temps est long et donc faut pas se
tromper donc un travail sur la recherche
et deux un travail qu'on conduit qu'on
conjugue avec un travail de
renouvellement qui a annoncé le
président de la République de
renouvellement forestier c'est
renouvellement des essences dans des
forêts qui sont en cours de
dépérissement ça c'est un élément qui
est très important un monde sur un texte
qui va être examiné dans les prochains
jours à l'Assemblée nationale la
proposition de loi du député la France
insoumise américain Caron qui vise à
interdire la corrida quelle est votre
position sur ce sujet ma position elle
est simple
ça fait partie des traditions
culturelles françaises la question n'est
pas d'être afficionados et d'être
d'aimer ou de ne pas aimer la corrida ça
fait partie des traditions françaises il
y a derrière là c'est le ministre de
l'Agriculture qui parle une filière
d'élevage qui entretient je pense à la
Camargue en particulier un paysage et
pas seulement un paysage une
biodiversité qui est exceptionnelle dans
ce territoire et donc dans le moment
qu'on traverse et c'est c'est un
rendez-vous pour beaucoup de gens très
populaire c'est par ailleurs emprunt de
beaucoup de culture locale et moi j'ai
trop de respect pour les cultures
locales même si ça n'est pas la culture
que je porte moi puisque étant plutôt
quelqu'un du Nord de la loi je trouve
que dans le moment qu'on traverse
essayons d'écouter les uns on peut pas à
la fois dire il faut respecter les
cultures la diversité de chacun et sur
un sujet comme ça qui est le même sujet
que d'autres ne pas le respecter donc je
je trouve que ce texte n'est pas
opportun pour dire les choses très
clairement une dernière question sur la
dissolution Stéphane
on parle beaucoup on en parle sans arrêt
dans tous les sens vous en pensez quoi
vous je pense qu'on en parle trop
favorable vous seriez favorable
ce n'est pas une décision du ministre de
l'Agriculture donc commençons par moi
j'essaie de m'occuper du périmètre
caminien quand vous comme vous le voyez
deux je trouve que les parlementaires de
la majorité essaie de faire un travail
dans des conditions qui sont difficiles
passer son temps tous les matins dire
attention comme si c'est comme si il
pouvait être sensible à ce type de
menage je pense que faut
arrêter
vous avez peut-être un petit un avis sur
la question
au fond elle était produite quand elle a
été produite par le sentiment que la
majorité
faisait défaut au sens dans sa cohérence
aujourd'hui la majorité ne fait pas
défaut le seul problème c'est qu'il y a
une majorité relative
et le deuxième hypothèse théorique c'est
est-ce qu'on est dans une situation de
blocage la vérité non d'abord il y a des
outils constitutionnels 49-3 pour les
éléments budgétaires et deux sur un
certain nombre de textes ça c'est encore
passé au Sénat je vois bien qu'il y a
des textes sur lequel on est capable
d'avancer et donc c'est pas blanc ou
noir cette affaire là il faut qu'on
essaie de trouver les voies et moyens
parce que l'exigence pour avancer et
pour produire des textes parce que ce
que aucun concitoyen que je croise dans
mon département ailleurs me dit alors
quand est-ce que vous allez dissoudre
ils me disent alors quand est-ce qu'on
essaie de sortir de cette crise
qu'est-ce qui va se passer sur
l'inflation est-ce qu'on aura des
produits alimentaires
aux oppositions je pense qu'on peut être
à toutes les oppositions on peut être
dit alors moi je vois bien les attitudes
du rassemblement national et de la
France insoumise qui quel que soit le
texte quel que soit l'objet quel que
soit le sujet
au fond fond commerce à la fois de la
crise dont on traverse et fonds commerce
de l'opposition pour l'opposition moi je
je pense que j'ai pas besoin de gens qui
viennent m'amener des problèmes j'ai
besoin de gens qui m'amènent des
solutions et donc partout il y aura des
gens qui cherchent des solutions et qui
se mettent dans la situation où
gouvernerait eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire une
situation de responsabilité pas
d'irresponsabilités je trouve ça sera un
bon chemin merci Marc